Welcome to open access.
This is our third is there it is.
This is our third annual open access
week celebration and we have a lot of
exciting things that we're going to
present this week. Lots of events. Uh,
we can have a keynote address today.
Uh,
that's going to be followed up by hands
on workshop about mashups skills from
the renowned Donald duck meets Glenn Beck,
creator to a panel of experts
about digital textbooks
as digital technology and
content. Deliberate questions
about access, copyright,
and fair use continue
to come to the surface.
This week's events offer
lots of opportunities to
explore these new areas of
creativity, scholarship and technology
and how they're all coming together.
Let me give you a little preview
of the week to come on Monday.
Today we have hacking pop culture with
remix video by John and Macintosh,
our keynote speaker for the week.
Tuesday, Rick remixed manifesto,
a movie here,
the Gould Auditorium at 11:00 AM 11:30
AM how to remix and reuse a workshop by
Jonathan McIntosh, which will be in room
1008 at 1:00 PM. That's tomorrow. Again,
Wednesday, free and open digital textbooks
perspectives on impossible future.
That would be a panel discussion and
room 1150 at 3:00 PM and on Thursday or
last event we'll be publishing smart how
to make your article visible. Room one
thousand9@twopmandifyouwanttogobackandlookatanyofthissoyoucanfinditonourmarriottlibrarydotwordpress.com
site.
I know you all memorize that really fast.
So you've got that and there'll be four
our staff announcements and continuing
and flash so you can figure out when
you're supposed to come to what end.
You're welcome to come to all of these
events this week. So that introduction,
let me turn it over to rob.
Gail was assistant professor of new
media and the Department of Communication
who will introduce our speaker today.
Yes, I'm Rob [inaudible] and the
Department of Communication. Um,
before I get started,
like to thank Joyce Analysis and Laurie,
the folks in library for making this
possible and also like to thank Bob Avery
who's the chair of the Department of
Communication for helping sponsor, uh,
Jonathan bringing your manner and those,
speaking of Jonathan Mackintosh,
he's a remix artist,
a self proclaimed pop culture hacker.
And if, I guess if you pressed me
wanting me to explain what that means,
I think of culture is something
about day to day life.
It's the life that we lead. It's kind
of our assumptions, it's what drives us.
And so a lot of what we get about
day to day life comes from the media.
And therefore if we want to think about
new messages that we want to think about
critiquing our culture, we have to tear
apart media. We have to critique it,
mash it up, dude, interesting
remix things. And that's
exactly what Jonathan does.
He's got a lot of uh,
excellent work out there.
I want to highlight a couple
of my favorites. Uh, his video,
Buffy versus Edward twilight remixed is
a masterpiece that in his word serves as
a metaphor for the ongoing battle between
opposing visions of gender roles in
the 21st century. It mixes Buffy the
vampire slayer of course with twilight.
And if I'm not mistaken,
there's a little bit of Harry Potter
in there just to touch yeah. And, uh,
in the video Edwards
obsessive stalking behavior,
which apparently is
acceptable and twilight, uh,
grates against and is over ultimately
overcome by the tenacious and self assured
Buffy, you know, says Buffy being
stocked isn't really a turn on for girls.
Buffy ultimately has enough spoiler alert,
cover yours if you must.
Buffy sleighs Edward
in right wing radio duck Macintosh uses
depression-era Donald Duck cartoons to
try to understand the popularity
of shock jock Glenn Beck,
especially in our current alien
or economy. Donald Duck could,
cannot find a job and has
his home foreclosed on
wonders why he's in such dire
economic straits. Then on the
radio, we hear three, two, one beck,
Glenn Beck promises to give
Donald all the answers,
but only after he shows out the money
for insider extreme. In the end,
Donald gets disillusioned
and he eventually overcomes
Beck's racist in divisive
rhetoric.
First part,
Glenn Beck has responded to this video
calling a and I think we'll see an
example of that calling
McIntosh's work quote,
incredible propaganda if we
follow Glenn Beck's logic. Uh,
what's your in store for today is a,
a talk from a long haired anti-American
communist Pinko hippie radical with
funding from socialists like Obama or
possibly acorn or maybe Mexican narco
terrorists. I'm not entirely
sure. Listen, well, dear audience,
that is if you think
the terrorists should,
when you like communism and
you hate America, um, no.
In all seriousness,
Jonathan Macintosh is a true artist.
He's keyed on what art
can be in the digital age.
Art can critique, art can
inspire, can drive thought.
It can expose the best
and worst of our culture.
You can bring together digital objects
and mash them together to build metaphors
and ideas.
Art Can change the world for the better.
Please join me in welcoming
Jonathan McIntosh.
Uh, thank you everyone. Is My
microphone on? Is it working? Um,
so that was, uh, that was
basically my whole, my whole
talk. I can just go home now.
Um, uh, so this is an html five web page.
Um, what you can find online,
uh, after the talk. Uh,
but it's also a presentation.
You do need the latest,
uh, Firefox or chrome browsers.
It's sort of we'll work in safari,
but only if you have like
5.1 0.1. Um, so let me just
start here. Um, like you said, I'm a pop
hold your hacker and to talk about
what that means in a little bit. Um,
I'm also not going to do
a big introduction because
I wanted, have somebody
else do that via video
in a second. Um, but, uh,
this is me so you can follow me
on Twitter. It's radical bites.
The hashtag that I'm going to
use for just this room here, um,
is Hashtag remix Utah. If you want to, um,
participate in the larger
discussion around open access week,
you can use Hashtag,
uh,
oh a week and that will sort of link you
into a larger conversation on Twitter.
Um, my youtube channel, it was rebellious
pixels and I have two websites.
One of them is a rebellious pickles.com.
That's where all my,
my video work and writing is.
Um,
and then I also blog at a website
called political remix, next video,
which is where we take,
um, we take I think,
interesting examples of politically
oriented video from around around the web
that,
that mashup other content.
And then we sort of write
about it and blog about it. Um,
it started as sort of an archiving
project, um, and it's still largely that,
but there's sort of people
engaging with it as well. Um,
and want to say political for this talk.
I'm,
I don't necessarily mean
government or elections, uh,
that sort of big p politics. Um, but I,
I actually mean it in a much broader
sense and that is to include race and
sexuality, gender, economy,
uh, as well as policy.
Um, so that's sort of a
wide ranging, a sampling of,
of I think some of the best a
remix videos on the web that,
that deal with remixing,
not just the footage but actually
we mixing the message of,
of mass media often too. So, um,
so start with, um, I like to start
with this first quote here. Uh,
the universe is made of
stories not of atoms.
What that means to me is that
the way that we sort of
understand our world,
the way that we understand
our place in it,
the relationships between
people and institutions, uh,
between people in governments, between
people in corporations is often, um,
to the stories were told and
the stories we tell, right? Um,
these narratives come in many forms.
Uh,
and often in today's Day and age,
uh,
those narratives, the popular narratives
are, are inside of popular culture, right?
So that's TV, that's movies, that's um,
that is music videos,
that's mainstream news. Um,
and that's where these sort of narratives
are told and then retold a and then
changed and transformed. Um, uh,
now that space, that pop culture
space is of course owned by a very,
very small owned and controlled by
a very, very small group of, of,
of corporate interests. And one of
the things that means is that the, uh,
majority of, of, of these stories
that we are engaging with have a very,
I think limiting and
limited set of values,
a set of myths,
a set of serve social norms
that they present to us, right?
It's actually a very narrow set
of ideas on race, on gender,
on, on economics, on sexuality. Right? Um,
and so for many people,
they don't get,
they don't get to see themselves
reflected or their lives reflected in mass
media to have to a very large degree.
And so what people have done for the
past several decades actually is they've
taken those pop culture stories,
whether it be a TV show or the news, uh,
and they have remixed them or change
them in some way to make them better
represent or better reflect where they're
coming from because they might not be,
uh,
they might not be represented.
One of my favorite examples of this
is star Trek, uh, which is, uh,
which is a very popular, uh, uh,
set of stories in our culture,
especially in, in, in the
West. Um, and one of the,
one of the striking things about it is
that there have been a, I think, five,
six television series now. Um, some
of them lasting seven years each.
There've been, um, uh, over
a dozen films and not, not,
there's not one queer characters,
not one gay character,
major character in that
entire thing. So, um,
so fans of star trek might say,
you know, I really liked star trek,
but it's missing something, right?
It's actually missing quite a,
quite a few things.
And so people will take fanfiction and
they will rewrite it and they'll, they'll,
they'll add things to that
narrative story that's missing.
So that's just one example. Um, so, uh,
how do people participate in this,
in this,
in this, uh, culture, right?
In this media culture. Uh,
and one of the ways they do that is,
is that they remix this quote. Uh,
I actually love this quote,
this quote is, he is from, uh,
the screenwriter for rebel,
rebel without a cause. Um,
any film is at the same time and
expression of a writer and that it's an
offering to the audience to
create their own film. Now,
when rebel without a cause came out,
he didn't actually mean this literally.
Uh, but with technology today,
it can be taken literally.
And I do take it literally,
you can literally remake the film.
You can literally rewrite the
film. Um, and that is I think,
what many mixers are doing.
Um,
and then lastly, uh, I talk about
myself as a pop culture hacker
and there's some confusion about
this word, uh, hacking. Um,
it often sort of brings to
mind a not so nice things. Um,
but I,
I actually liked this definition.
This is temperate love with the
chaos computer club in Germany.
And he says a hat that the
hacker approaches the world
breaks it apart to better
understand how it works in order to figure
out what can be done with it. Right.
Um, and that's, that's
the way that hackers as a,
as a subculture have
traditionally approached things.
They have, they have, um,
approached a piece of piece of technology
or computer code, and then they,
if they have said, I want to
know how this works. Right?
So they take it apart and then
they, then they say, well, you know,
because it's built like this,
it means that it can do these 10 things
that apple or Samsung didn't want you to
do with it. Um, but it's possible. And
so with what they'll do is they'll make,
they'll push the technology to its limits,
right?
They'll see what else can be done with
it. Um, and so in that, in that sentence,
it's a, it's a deconstruction and
then it's a reconstruction. Right? Um,
and that's sort of what I do when I
approached television or the movies.
Uh,
I think of it in terms of here's this
thing that I'm given on this face value,
um, uh, story, uh, um, a narrative,
a visual representation,
and I can take it apart.
I can see how it works.
You know, I can literally,
I can literally take it apart as well
as, as, um, as, as sort of deconstructed,
right? Find out what the embedded
myths are, find out what the, um,
what the,
uh,
the embedded messages might be buying it
with the value system of that piece of
media is. Um, and then I can, once I have
it broken down into its components, I can,
I can then say, okay, well, because
it works like this because these are,
this is the way that it's built. This
is what drives this, this narrative.
I can put it back together in a
different way. I can transform it, right.
And tell a different story
with these parts. Um,
and so that's what ha pop culture
hacking means to me. I mean,
I use that because I think it's a,
it's actually a little bit
more descriptive a of a
term then remix or Mashup.
Um, I use those terms as well. Uh,
and I think that those, those, uh,
that work is very important. Um, and
often fantastic. And in terms of,
of adding to a larger debate.
But, um, it's not just about,
often the stuff that I find most
interesting and most meaningful and most
poignant is not just about taking two
things and sticking them together and to
see what happens.
Sometimes it is that,
but often there's a lot of
thought that goes into it.
It's a very intentional process of,
of seeing what it is that's in
the meaning of this message,
in this piece of media and what's the
meaning of this message in this piece of
media? And then putting them together,
right. Um, uh, removing certain parts,
adding certain parts to set,
say something different.
And I think that that actually is
more than just sort of sticking things
together to see what happens.
Um, and incidentally,
I think that most people who do remix
work actually do a lot more of that
intentional and careful
analytical process.
It's not just taking things as
sticking them together. Um, so,
um, I thought that I was show
you an example of this. Uh,
using my own work. I made this video, um,
right wing radio duck. Uh, it
took about three months. Um,
it's about seven minutes long.
So it's,
it's the same length as
most Disney cartoons,
a classic era cartoons.
Um,
it uses over 50 Donald duck cartoons,
um,
as well as some Mickey mouse and some
goofy that are thrown in there. Um,
it also uses,
uh,
about about 50 episodes of Glen
Beck's radio and TV show. Um,
cut up. Uh, so this is, this
is the version on Youtube,
but I'm not going to show you a
different version of this. Um,
it's actually the same video,
but, um, it's html five.
And with html five video
becomes an element, uh, in a,
in a web page that can interact
with data. Uh, and so, uh,
I find that personally very geeky
and fascinating. Um, so, uh,
the way that that this,
this demo works is that you've got the
video playing as an html five video.
What that means is that the video element
and the timecode of that element can
be, uh, can be,
can trigger events in this
case is javascript events.
So what I've done is I've inputted,
I've input all of the footage that I used,
all of the episodes of, of
uh, of the classic cartoons,
all of the episodes of Glenn Beck Show,
um, as well as some footnotes that,
that I have that I was using in
the creation of this process. Uh,
and then some Wikipedia articles that
deal with the specific topic that I was
trying to get at, right? So it's adding
this sort of layer of metadata on top of,
of, of, of a piece of
video. Um, uh, incidentally,
the red text are links.
So if you want to see either the Donald
Duck cartoon or the Glenn Beck episode
in its original context,
you can click on that and you'll take
it to the original source so you can see
it. I'm so sorry. I'm
going to show you this.
Yeah. And this is an html five web page
using the video tag, which is a new,
any tag to the village of you
who have already seen this.
You can then watch the, uh, the
metadata that's dynamically appearing.
For those of you who haven't seen it, then
you can ignore the metadata or try to,
it's a little bit,
oh,
[inaudible].
Do you feel like you're working harder
and harder these days just to stay
financially afloat while fat
cats get richer and richer?
It's not just a feeling
and you're not alone.
The income gap between the
rich and poor in America,
is that an eight year high as the
largest differential since the period
immediately proceeding.
Gotcha.
Labs
are getting more while the have
nots are getting less. Meanwhile,
government isn't helping
decades of rising inequality.
Yeah.
Slap Blah, blah, blah.
Oh,
well, I'm going to duck
that beer right out of job.
Gotcha.
Hey.
Wow.
Great. Welcome to the program.
My name is Glenn Beck.
The bad news is just multiplying.
Our economy is tanking.
It doesn't show signs of
improving their people.
Losing jobs are government responds to
the problems with bailouts and when you
call them up and say,
what are you doing?
You don't get any response
or not listening to you.
Wall Street owns our government.
What did we get here?
I think a lot of people feel like they're
alone and they just want to give up.
Wow. Wow. I love my country.
It is the shining example of a place
where people work together in peace and
friendship and worship God and
make things better together. Well,
the idea that built America are
being lost and perverted. Wow.
Wow.
Ask yourself this one question.
How many Marxist Communist anticapitalist
do you have around you on a daily
basis?
Yup.
The truth is that you are
the defender of liberty.
Our situation is bad.
There are Nazis in America,
Nazis and communists.
You have to think like a German June,
the higher higher.
There he is,
eight perfect storm formulating and it
is here we are entering a dangerous and
scary time. America, the country
will be washed with blood.
These people don't mess around.
They are taking you to a place
to be slaughtered. Death camp.
What planet am I landed on?
It's like the damn planet of the apes.
Did I slip through a worm hole in the
middle of the night and this looks like an
error. We're in a dark, dark place.
We've got some dark dudes coming our way.
Black Panthers, acorn reparation,
welfare. Jeremiah writes,
jumps on my himself. Alcaide ran
Islamic Jihad lists, Venice, Venezuelan,
immigration, Mexicans, refugees,
Hispanic, South America, legal, alien,
Mexico, Shiny. Every one is coming.
He enemy is not only in the
gates there inside the house
as atmos come up, Leon
pestle. Oh, La Mexican.
Erica.
It's like a pack of wild clue.
Joe's ripping up the flesh
of the American people,
ruff, ruff, drug lords,
illegal aliens,
Mexico.
They're going to start
getting more and more violent.
We had been tossed into boiling water.
These people are cannibalizing
from Hannibal Lecter. Zinging us.
That's what Barack Obama is
doing to the American people.
I'm hoping the guy with horns
doesn't actually show up.
Everything is about to
change to the extreme,
the insider extreme. We invite
you to join up before 995 a month.
It's going to explain
everything that is going on.
Nope.
Hmm.
Hi.
Yes. Insider extreme is up
and on. Hello? Yes. Sick,
twisted freak, and welcome to
the extremists. Who are you?
Why not? Why isn't that a name
of some stupid Disney curt,
you're going to ask any question.
Oh, sucks to be you, doesn't it?
When you bought a house,
you bet that you could pay it,
that nothing would happen. It
happened. You lost, move on.
Boohoo cry me a river. Hey, I
got an idea. Listen to this.
Get a job,
Lazy Slob that refuses to get
off the couch and get a job.
[inaudible]
um, thank you. Uh,
so what I like about a five is it
allows you, it allows me as a, as a,
as a filmmaker,
as a remix artist,
to present a very detailed
set of my sort of,
of notes about my process.
Um,
it also allows you to connect back to the
original sources, right? So one of the,
one of the principles of fair use, which
I can go over very quickly in a minute,
um, that I always advocate is to
cite your sources, right? So in the,
in the same way that you would
quote from, uh, from text, uh,
if you're quoting from video
to make a remix, you should
cite that. Um, and so, uh,
occasionally on, on, on Youtube or
on Vimeo, you'll see people who have,
who have made a remix and they've tried
to cover up that fact because they think
that it's maybe the logo that we'll get
them in trouble. So if it's CNN though,
I'll try to cover up the logo or
boiler the logo. Um, but actually, uh,
what I ever pay people to do is I say, you
know, leave that and, and say, you know,
where you got it from, um, what episode it
is. Because one, you're citing a source,
you're saying, I'm using this,
it's, it's fair use. Uh, and, uh,
if other people are, the remixers
are people who are watching your, uh,
your video interest in the topic,
they can go there and find and
look at those original sources. Um,
and so this is just sort of, is a way
for me to, to present those upfront.
And I'm just saying, well, you know, if,
if you think that I was unfair
to Glenn Beck, you can go into,
you can listen to those soundbites, um,
in, in, in their original context. I mean,
one of the things that I tried to do
and one it was very important to me,
was to keep, um, both of these,
uh, cartoon characters, uh,
consistent with their, uh, with
their media persona, right? So, uh,
I wanted to keep Donald Duck Donald Duck.
I didn't want Donald Duck to
do things that don't look,
wouldn't do. Um, uh, and so,
uh, obviously I'm actually using
Donald Duck. So that becomes, um,
it's almost seems self evident,
but you can actually make Donald duck
do things that are very and Donald Duck
like with remix. Um, but I wanted
to keep Donald Duck as Donald Duck.
I wanted him to react in situations in
the way that he might have done, um,
sort of in a very hot headed
and a little bit overblown way,
sort of fall for things very quickly and
then realize that maybe he's been duped.
These are all things that happen over
and over and over again in a, in,
in Donald Duck cartoons. Um, uh, of
which I'm a fan and I have watched,
I watched since I was very young.
One of the only things I was allowed to
watch in my very conservative household
was, um, was Disney channel.
And so I watched all of these
over and over again to have,
I've had the memorized. And so
when I came to this project, I, uh,
Donald Duck was the natural choice.
Um,
and ultimately to keep Glenn Beck a
relatively consistent with his message,
I didn't, I didn't want, you
know, it's very easy to, um,
it's very easy to make him say things
that are sort of totally insane. Uh,
he kind of says things are totally
insane once in a while anyway,
but you can sort of, you can very easily
take them out of context and make them,
make him sound like he's talking about,
you know, aliens from Mars. Right.
And that's not what I wanted to do.
I actually wanted to keep his message
relatively consistent and that's,
that's why the, um, uh, the links
are there so you can follow it back.
I just wanted to pick up the
themes of what he was saying,
but keep his message consistent.
Um, and then have the, have the,
to sort of interact in a way. So it
technically it's out of context of course,
because it's, you know, I've removed the
media clips and made something new, but,
uh, I tried to keep their, um,
general persona, uh, accurate, um,
and as much as you can. Um, so, uh,
this, I put this up, I, uh,
I premiered this at the opening video
conference in New York City, uh,
and I think I was on Friday
maybe. And by Monday, um,
he had already gone viral and so we'd had,
in the first week it had about
half a million views, um,
and it was on every political blog you'd
think of including Glenn Beck's block.
Um, uh, Roger Ebert tweeted about it
and he said, everyone should watch it.
Um, and uh, and he put a little urgency in
the, in his tweet. He was like, you know,
everyone should watch this
before Disney takes it down.
And so everyone went to watch it right
away, which was, I was, I appreciate it.
He also blogged about it at the,
at the Sun Times.
And The Washington Post called me and
that was about the half million mark.
And they said, uh, this the
Washington Post, and, uh,
we would like to talk to
you about your little video,
which I thought it was nice of them,
um,
and your times to just
don't worry about it. Uh,
and it sort of ballooned from there.
John Cusak tweeted about it. Um, uh,
for some reason bill O'Reilly also
tweeted about it. He tweeted the video.
So I don't know if he'd seen
it at that point or not, but
he didn't say anything about
it as no commentary, just
watch this, uh, which is, uh,
to me, maybe he's not in control of
his own Twitter account. Um, but then,
so then on Monday, someone sent me, um,
something like this.
Uh,
and this is a video clip of
Glenn Beck on his radio show.
He has about, he, he did
have five hours of, of, uh,
airtime to fill every day. Uh, now it's
four cause he's not on, on Fox every day.
Um, so it's a lot of time. So I understand
that he needs to fill that time. Uh,
and he decided to fill
that time like this.
Um,
Donald Duck meets Glenn Beck.
Now this took some time, some
talent in some money. Cool.
It's what, eight minutes?
It is. Yeah, it is.
It is some of the best wellmade
propaganda I have ever seen.
Um, but I just want to, I just,
I just want to show you
what was on his website. Hi.
Um, so I'm going to have Glenn Beck
introduced me in a more formal way.
I didn't do that earlier. Um, and
since he has so much time to feel,
he reads my entire bio,
uh,
which was fantastic for me
because now I don't have to do it.
Aim Is Jonathan McIntosh.
I'm a pop culture hacker,
video remix artist,
photographer and new media teacher,
consultant and fair use activist.
I also have worked on numerous media and
social justice related projects in the
United States and around the
world in my stairs. Spare time.
I helped co edit the blog of political
remix video and I am a member of the open
video alliance political remix video.
My video work remixes and transforms fee
of fragments of mass media pop culture
to tell alternative political,
social and cultural narratives.
Basically I'm a pop culture hacker,
but instead of a computer
code I had television.
My political remix is appear online and
also in film festivals and on community
TV stations and new media
conferences globally.
Last year I was a consultant for
remix America Online project.
Last summer also co-taught a two week
intensive workshop called the fair use.
Remax Institute was Chicago youth
using remix video as a media
literacy tool if I'm not mistaken.
Um,
some of these remix videos,
um,
it's very interesting,
I believe get federal funding.
I believe it was one,
one of these things that he's involved
in was one of the first to receive
federal funding to just
understand that culture.
We're looking into the funding of this
gentleman and the incredible propaganda
against me.
Like you've never seen using
Disney and Disney cartoons.
Of course it's all fair
use so they can use Disney.
Apparently Disney doesn't
have a problem with, um,
with Donald Duck cartoons
now being remixed,
politicized and politicized
for the progressive left.
I know a lot about Walt Disney.
I know how much he hated the union because
he thought they were communists. What,
um,
I know how much Disney hated the enemies
of this country and the constitution,
namely the Communists,
the Socialists,
the union organizers,
dare I say it,
the progressive's,
but apparently they don't
have a problem with this.
I guess it's all fair use and we'll
find out if it's been federally funded,
you know,
as part of the stimulus package or one
of those NEA packages of the White House
is simultaneously involved in and,
and an off time volts
to quote Gandhi and play,
um,
Indian music and it's offensive anyway.
Um,
so was fantastic because he proved pretty
much every point that I was trying to
make in that little response.
Um, uh, incidentally,
I'm still haven't gotten my check
from Obama after all that work. Um,
you know, obviously I made this in
my living room in my spare time, uh,
over a period of three
and a half months. Um, uh,
I didn't get any funding for it.
I haven't been paid for it since or then.
Um, so, you know, uh,
and I, um, as far as I know,
none of the projects I've worked
on have gotten any stimulus money.
As much as I would like to
get some stimulus money,
uh, it hasn't happened. Um,
so we sort of, you sort of
proves all my points there.
Um, and so that, um, you know,
a bunch of people saw this and it was,
it was sort of talking about a little bit,
but this response didn't go viral in the
way the original video did. Um, however,
um, in the, in the, in the,
in the way that this sort of call
and response remix and, and, um, uh,
transformative do dialogue
happens, uh, often, uh,
on the Internet these
days. Um, someone else,
another remix her named icat three eight
one took Glen Beck's response and took,
I'm Mickey Mouse Video,
um,
to make another response.
So this is,
this is a remixed response to
going back to response to my remix,
which is a remix, which is a response
to going back. Okay. It's follow that.
Um, and I actually think that this is even
better than Glenn Beck responding in a
lot of ways.
[inaudible]
there is a,
a story on Donald Duck meets Glenn back.
It is some of the best
propaganda against me.
Like you've never seen using
Disney and Disney cartoons,
but I just want to, I
just, if I'm not mistaken,
some of these remix videos I
believe get federal funding.
The Communists,
socialists,
the union organizers, Jonathan
Macintosh, the enemies,
yet another unbelievable attack.
But I guess it's all fair use and it's
okay because the truth shall set you
free.
[inaudible]
so I, you know, I, that is my one,
my favorite things ever. Um, the,
this response also went viral. So
it sort of a, a week later, uh,
this one was also posted it on and
many of those of those blogs and in my,
my remix now has about a million
and a half views, I think. Um,
and this one has about
a million. So it's, uh,
it's sort of gained a lot of
popularity. Um, and there's,
I think there's very, very little
that you can do with, with, uh, um,
that amount of sort of hyperbolic rhetoric
that has very little basis in reality
except mix it with a cartoon. It seems
to fit really nicely. And so, okay, so,
so let's, let's, that's an example. Um,
I just wanna talk a little bit
about fair use. You know, I, I, I'm,
I'm not going to focus on it a
lot because I feel like it's,
it's been covered in, in many places
and there's, there's, you know,
there's an enormous amount of,
of,
of academic work done on
this topic, um, but it's,
want to go over it very quickly in terms
of some of the questions that I asked
myself. Um, so, uh, in terms of fair use,
some of the questions that
I ask that I ask myself,
and this is not all that
fair use encompasses,
this is just sort of the things that I,
I, uh, I talked to remixers about, right?
So, um, is, is the remix
work transformative, right?
Um,
that is,
does it change and transform the
original into something new? Right.
And is it distinguishable
as something new? Um,
is the remix work a commentary
at criticism or a parody?
Right now? It doesn't have to be
a negative commentary. It can be,
it can be a celebration.
That can be commentary,
can be an argument that can be commentary.
There are many ways that you can have
commentary, but does it comment on,
uh, on the source? Um,
and then, uh, one of the questions
that there's often asked in this,
in this list of, of questions about
fair use is how much is borrowed.
There's no set amount.
There's no set amount in terms of words,
letters,
there's no set amount in terms of
video footage or sound clips. Um, the,
uh, the doctrine, the fair
use doctrine says that you,
you can use as much as you need,
right?
Purposely vague because what if you need,
you know, you might need 10 seconds,
you might need the entire thing, but
you might, but you will. Then of course,
we'd have to transform it in a
very significant way. Right? Um,
so there, there, there is no seven
second rule. There's no 32nd rule.
There's no two paragraph rule,
there's no rule at all.
It is how much you need and that you
know, is going to be determined, um,
by anyone who sort of evaluating whether
it's fair use or not. Um, and then the,
one of the other things
that, that is often, uh,
is often brought up is what is the effect
on the original works value and that
that's, that's the market value. So, um,
when this is sort of a disgust in the,
in the courts, what they mean
by that is, you know, um,
if someone watches my Donald Duck Remix,
do they no longer have to buy a or see
any other Donald duck cartoon or have I
shown them everything
clearly? I haven't. Um,
I've showed them a few seconds of
Volvo, very large body of work. Um,
uh, and so, and that actually
I think is less important,
at least in, in, in the court cases
that I've looked at is less important.
The most important factors.
The first one,
which is whether it's transformative or
not, that is the most important thing.
It has to be transformative.
Um, incidentally, a,
there's no rule that says you
can't make money off of it either.
There's no rule that says
it has to be noncommercial.
You can do a fair use remix and you can
make a commercial. Um, probably, uh,
then it's transformative.
Nis is going to be incredibly
important in that termination. Um,
but there's no rule that says, I mean,
if you, if you have it not noncommercial,
you might get a, um, uh, judges
leeway a little bit. But there's,
there's no rule that says you have to.
Um,
I also love this quote from 1839 works
for value only if they give rise to
better ones. Um, uh, this actually
he's a, he's a German national,
a naturalist. He was
a, a natural scientist.
Um, and, uh, so there were
sort of working on, um,
working in the, sort of the same
fee fields. Darwin, right? I mean,
so he's talking about
scientific work here. Um, but
I think that the quote can be,
can be appropriated to mean
art or media as well. Um,
so that's a very, very brief
overview of, of various,
if you have other questions we can, we can
chat about it. Uh, I'm happy to do that,
but I think there's a more interesting
question that I want to bring up.
And then it's a question about the ethics
of appropriation because I think that
has a separate completely
separate question actually
then the legal and fair use
question. And it's a question that
gets asked I think a little bit less.
And there's a lot of focus
in, um, especially in,
in an open access spaces like this
one, uh, about the legality, right?
It's all about the legality. Is
it legal, is it not like, well,
there are lots of things that are
legal that are not necessarily good,
like ethical I think.
Um,
and there are lots of things that are
illegal that might be ethical, right?
So I think that there is another
question sort of separate.
So I want to separate this question
very clearly from the use question. Um,
so put that aside and we'll talk
about the ethics here for a second.
So the has some of the questions
that I asked when I, when I,
when I'm going to Remix, uh, some piece
of media, right? So I asked, uh, you know,
who owns, uh, the source media
and who's depicted in it?
And so for a Disney, right, for instance,
it's, it's owned by Disney, right?
One of the largest multinational
corporations are the richest in the world.
And so I, that's who owns that. Um, uh,
in terms of Glenn back, there's
a, there's a variety of owners.
Fox News is one owner.
Um,
and then Glenn Beck has a variety of
his own companies that, that, that, uh,
and then there's a radio program as well.
So it's right,
there's about three
different owners there.
But all of those are corporate entities.
They're all relatively well to do. Um,
and so they occupy a position
of power. Who's depicted, uh,
obviously Donald duck is a, is a
cartoon. Um, uh, and then in, in,
in Glen Beck's voice, that's, that's
going back. So there's, there's a very,
very critical questions. And I sort
of asking a, who is in this media? Um,
and then one of the values,
what are the messages he
embedded in that source material?
We talked about that in terms of, of um,
of Glenn Beck and Donald Duck, right?
There's, I think two separate
sets of values. Um, some
of them are contradictory,
some of them line up very well
in those two pieces of media.
And so I tried to pull out those things,
including some of the racial stereotyping
that was happening both in Glen Beck's
program and also, uh, in the, in the
older Disney stuff. Um, and then, uh,
I think one of the most important things
is what positions of privilege and
power they hold relative to me. Right?
Because when I remixed something,
I'm kind of looking in terms of
where do I sit on the, on, on the,
on the power scale, right? On
this sort of social, um, uh,
power scales, right? Um,
uh, where, where am I?
And then where is this media that I'm
mixing it and my am I looking up and I am,
I am remix mixing people who were in the
public sphere, government officials, um,
uh, corporate entities,
right? Celebrities, people
who have a lot of money,
or am I looking down in the social sphere,
people who were right and I'm mixing
people who are homeless or it makes the
people who are, you know, who, who, who,
who might be oppressed in various ways.
And so I was asked those questions when I,
um,
when I remixed and I try to always remix,
especially if I'm being critical,
I, I try to remix things that are above
me and in relatively in these sort of
social space spaces, right? Um, uh, that's
not true across the board men, everyone,
there's don't do that. Um, it's very easy
to pick on people who are below you in,
in, in, in power and privilege levels.
I'm, it gets a quick laugh, uh,
but I feel like it does some damage and
we'll talk about that in a second. Um,
so that's what I keep in mind that
certainly not what everyone does and these
aren't, these aren't rules, these are just
sort of things that I keep in mind. Um,
uh, right. And this is a fantastic quote
from bell hooks is one of my favorites.
It sort of talks about this.
There's a there, especially
in spaces, but also in, in,
in artists spaces and sometimes
in music spaces as well.
There's a tendency to um,
try to be transgressive for
transgressive Sake, right?
They try to be, um, uh, to try sort
of a be against the grain or a or a,
because for the sake of being rebellious,
right?
As opposed to thinking about
what it is like, you know,
I want to be rebellious for a purpose.
And what is that purpose? What,
what does that new message,
right on my remix mixing just the material
because I want to remix something and
it's kind of trend,
a subset of subversive,
what I want to remix the material for
some reasons and have some sort of message
behind it. Um, so, uh, some
examples of, of, of that.
So I think about it in terms of, you
know, artists or media makers are, um,
are using this tool of remix,
uh, to, to say something. Um,
and often when you talking about comedy,
you talk about, you know, you can comedy,
you can, you can, you can adjust your sort
of throwing rocks as a comedian, right?
You're throwing rocks and you've seen him
if it hits and it's, it's, it's funny.
Um,
and so you can either throw rocks up
right at people who are above you in terms
of wealth, in terms of, um,
of various hierarchies or you can
throw rocks that are down, uh,
and throwing rocks down is very
easy. This is, this is an example,
people who are throwing rocks up some
of these memes or some of these remixes
here, um, at, at, at,
at more powerful people and more
and more powerful institutions. Um,
and I think that these challenge those
systems, right? The challenge status quo,
they challenge norms. Um, and I think
often in a very positive way, not always.
Um, there are certainly some, uh,
there's some back and forth here,
but I feel like they sort
of bs one sort of tend to,
I don't know how many of you
have recognized any of these,
any of these images here? Just
a couple of you. Um, so, uh,
just one of them Gaddafi,
he, um, when, when,
as the protests began in a,
in February, he gave a speech,
uh, from a little car
with an umbrella, right?
And it was a very strange speech, um, one,
one of a series of very strange speeches
that he gave at that point. And, uh, uh,
and especially in, in the Arabic
speaking world, this image became a meme,
you know,
so people would make little youtube
videos of themselves with umbrellas and it
was like as a whole umbrella meme
that those are spread. Um, and,
and then he did another one where he
could get another speech where he,
where he said, uh, that
the protests for democracy,
we're being controlled by the United
States and al Qaeda with hallucinogenics
that they had put in people's nest cafe.
Right?
This is like a national speech
that he gave and this is why.
And so that was his reason. So nest cafe
became this big thing like, you know,
if you drink last cafe, you'll freak out
and try to overthrow the government. Um,
and so that was, you know,
another sort of mean that, that,
that people picked up on it. And again,
they are there. They're using this,
this remix footage just sort of make fun
of and trying to disempower this very
powerful figure. Um, uh, first
world problems is another meme.
It's a,
it's an image macro that people will
often use this image or other ones which
are then sent. Some of them are
quite good. Uh, not all of them.
Obviously there are, there are,
there are gems. Um, this next one,
privileged nine dude, I mean, have you
heard of the privilege denying dude? Uh,
it's, I mean it's, it's actually quite
brilliant. Um, sort of, they found these,
these, these images are very smug
looking, you know, dot com, uh,
a hipster kids and they, uh, uh,
they would just write things that,
that they had heard their male
colleagues say about them, you know, uh,
so you know, your, your, or that
they, that they had sort of not said,
but sort of meant. Right. So, um,
your ideas sound so much better when I
rephrase it. Right. That's a classic one.
I think, um, and that got very popular
as well. There was also backlash,
I think against it. It was pretty bad.
Um, hype, which was making fun of them.
Obama's award winning PR
campaign to become president.
I'm actually won the marketer
of the year for that campaign.
So that was sort of talking
about that, um, Tom Cruise, uh,
has, uh, gets no end of, uh, of
being made fun of for various, uh,
is I think is the one where he's jumping
on the couch with Oprah. When you that,
um, anonymous, I feel like it's
a bit of a mixed, a mixed bag.
Sometimes they go after, um, uh, I think,
and it actually more recently
they've been going after, uh,
Dick dictators and systems of power.
They don't always do that,
but I feel like they've been sort of
tending in that in that way recently. Um,
they were also have a of an
operation against child pornography,
which they're trying to take down
all of the servers that host it,
which I feel like it's a
positive thing. Um, uh,
Bill O'Reilly had a brilliant freak out
that people made into a dance remix.
Many times you haven't seen it.
It's definitely not say for work,
but it's pretty funny. Um,
and then this one is, um, uh,
I think I believe is Sarah Pailin,
constitutional scholar, which
also very funny. Um, uh,
so some of them tend to be a little sexist
and I think you have to kind of sort
through it and find the, find
the good ones. Um, so, okay,
so those are those throwing rocks up.
You just throwing rocks down.
How many you should recognize these,
any of these images are memes, right?
If you don't, great. Good, good for you.
Don't, don't go looking for them. Um,
uh, they're sort of all, you
know, all things that were,
became very popular or they were,
they were sort of remix memes that
tended to make fun of people. Um,
uh, so make fun of Queer kids was a very,
or gay kids will, it was, it was a very,
it was a very popular thing to do.
It's,
and you could have easy kick at
people who are lower than you.
And the social scale usually. Um, this,
this next one is a show called lazy town.
I mean, you've heard of lazy
town is, there's a Nickelodeon
show, um, for kids. This,
this woman, this young girl was 12,
uh, in this, in the shot here. Um,
and she sort of sings and dances
and, uh, um, a shot in Iceland, uh,
she became a meme because they, um,
a bunch of people decided that she,
that they wanted to sexualize her and
so they put her on all kinds of horrible
sexual situations. Um, so, uh,
uh, you've got the golden voice, which
people sort of, some of them celebrate it,
but a lot of them I felt like made fun of.
Um, and then it goes down the line, uh,
instantly. Obama is in both of these,
right? He's, he's in both. Uh, because I,
I feel like there are, there are different
ways that you can critique power.
One of them is to pick on his, on his
race. One of them just pick on his,
on his political positions. Um, so, uh,
these are the questions that I ask
myself. I ask myself, you know, um,
what are the power relationships
here? All right. Um,
and then who's the target
and where do they sit? Um,
and I, I, you know, I
hope that this, you know,
that these become popular
and I hope that these don't,
that's not always the case. Um,
so, uh, that's about 45 minutes.
I want to leave some time for questions.
I want to show you one quick thing
before I go. Uh, this is, um,
a o five remix video, uh, for education.
And so this is a project that I'm working
on called the gendered advertising
remixer.
Uh,
and so this is the website that we
sort of built for their, for their,
for the demo.
This is just,
you're really a prototype and this is the
flash version that we're working on. A,
and this is the new html five
version without flash silage of five.
These are all videos that you can,
that you can play with. Um, uh, and
in, in remix and TV. Whenever I
look at TV, I'm always thinking,
how could this be different? You
know, what are the messages here? Uh,
how could they be mixed up? What can be
different, right? So, you know, when,
when I go see a film, I might be, I
might like certain aspects of the film.
I might be disappointed with other
aspects of the film. And so in my mind,
I started mixing things up. All
right? So I might go to a CSC, a film,
and I might like the cinematography
and I like, like the dialogue,
but there is no women in the film.
And so, which happens quite a lot. Uh,
and so I will,
I will pretend and all sort of in my mind,
switch out the actor for an actress and
just see what that would do in my mind.
Right? What, what, what, what would
that change the story? Um, and so, uh,
it's a great way to watch Harry
Potter, by the way. If you,
if you switch her money and Harry
in your mind as you watch it,
it becomes quite subversive. Um,
anyway, so, uh, this is, uh, you know,
I was watching Nickelodeon and I was
watching a cartoon network and I noticed
that the ads, um, that really
something new, but the ads are, uh,
are very segregated in terms of
gender and it sort of, you know,
you have one ad directed at boys and
then another ad direct at girls and then
boys and the girls sort
of stackers that way. Um,
and they are incredibly
specific in terms of the,
uh,
the key skill sets that are being taught,
the values that are being taught.
Um, what it says about, you know, uh,
about what it, what it means to be female
versus male in a, in, in, in the culture.
And if you just look at the types of
skills that are being displayed here, um,
and, and, and the value sets, and
then you ask yourself like, you know,
which kind of, um, what kind of, you know,
what kind of careers might come out of
this set of skills versus come up with
that set of skills. Right? You, you get
diametrically opposed and very narrow,
uh, um, and stereotyped
gender roles, right? So in,
in, in, in, in the girl's side,
across the board, you know,
there might be veterinarian,
like that might be the most
sort of career oriented thing.
Everything else is being a mom makeup,
finding a husband,
you know, um, and the technology is
all about shopping or finding a man,
right? So if there is technology
it shopping, finding man,
uh, over over here, right?
So you, but you also have some,
some positive stuff, right?
So when I talked to middle schoolers about
the stuff, I, you know, I say, you know,
what are the positive things? While
there's cooperation, there's compassion,
there's caregiving is lots of things
that are, that are positive here. Um,
not just negative. And then there were
lots of things that are positive here,
you know, um, confidence being, uh,
being in control of your environment
and building and creating, right?
But there's also a lot of aggression,
um,
an enormous amount of competition and
almost no cooperation whatsoever. Right?
And so what happens if you kind
of explain that to, to youth, uh,
and you can kind of have
a discussion about it,
but I find it much more effective if
you can let them do the deconstructing
themselves and actually do it literally.
And so for instance, in this case,
you can take a Polly pocket
airplane for instance,
and you can take the Gi Joe Command base,
um,
and depending on how fast the connection
is here, you can create your own mashup.
It's a great thing. Yes. The runway,
fashion
jumbo jet,
you put it together or they
don't think sold separately.
Uh, that's so not only is it
sort of fun to play with, uh,
any sort of gets a lot of people's laugh,
but you can,
but it becomes really apparent, right?
So you can swap them and you can,
so Gi Joe, pimp mobile headquarters
converts it to a massive battle station.
Always ready for action. Gi Joe
are you in? You can join today.
Got Gi joe.com the place that they get
the vehicles, all separate batteries,
not included adults simply
required as we're going along.
Um, yeah, they're just some
of my favorites. And you know,
there's about 400 possibilities
here just with this. Um, let's see.
Audio and then, uh, let's see. Video.
Let's do my little pony.
Yeah.
Oh No.
You know what we're going to do?
We're going to do video of Betty
Spaghetti. That's very good.
And then we'll do talk at the TACO trucks
and we'll hope that our internet can
new from the Taco garage,
not machines, three sizes,
one system you can build up and
customize your heavy duty truck.
All right, so this is, this
is, this is a little bit slow,
but I am going to show you this. So
this is, this is the flash version, um,
which we built as well.
Uh, for people who can't,
who is systems can't handle a Ishma five.
So we'll try to build it in
flash and see what happens. Uh,
we're spreading spaghetti.
Here's spaghetti video
and then talk a truck's.
Here we go, yes. Audio and we'll see
if this will work. I'm so, I'm sorry.
Starting to build a curriculum around
this, right? It's all fair use.
It's all transformative. Um,
education in all purposes is another,
is another fair use.
Well,
it seems like our Internet
here is a little slow anyway.
You can go play with this cause
it's online. See if you go to a,
if you were to gender remixer a.com,
you can play with it and
you can make your own.
I'm the cool thing about this one.
Let's see if it works
from the top
three sizes.
One system you can build up and
customize your heavy duty truck.
Tons of parts get drop the motor
into any modern machine, Tonka mom,
that's a top.
Um,
and so with the flash version right now,
we had it set up so you can download
that to your desktop or you can send it
directly to youtube. You can put on
your own youtube channel. And so when,
when you, um, are, are building things
and, um, I think about this in terms of,
you know,
in terms of Remix,
in terms of seeing the world as not
just something that you're given,
but something that you can
make something out of. Um,
and you can sort of talk
back to this is this is,
this is the one on one of
the first stages, right? It
sort of a gateway, right?
So you,
you start by making something in one
of these applications and then you can
learn the tools to go and make things, um,
uh, on your own. Even if you, you know,
went when I,
when I've done this workshop before,
even when a young people go home and
don't necessarily make another remix their
thinking in that way, or they've
already, they, they're, they're going in,
they're watching television and then
not watching him the same way, right?
They're watching it in terms of what they,
what's behind it and how it's built and
what maybe they could do with it. Um,
and so even if they don't actually
make something, again, that the,
in terms of critical media
literacy skills, um, they're
starting to see that, that,
that process and what's behind
a lot of it out that made you,
so I think I'll stop here and we'll
can do questions. Um, and, uh,
I'm willing to stay for
however long people want. Um,
[inaudible]
you don't have questions?
I'll just keep talking forever.
Right now. I'll say rewrite blowing
line with the Obama White House.
Great. Um, do you have any inkling
as to how that will change beer use?
Um,
given his track record of not hopeful,
um,
uh,
the Obama White House has been,
we talked a good talk and
then when they got in there,
they have been pretty much doing
whatever the, um, in a way,
whenever the big media companies
want, uh, tried to spin it. Um,
the way that a lot of the sort of fair
use stuff is one and defended his bike by
a makers and the lawyers and remixers who
get together and challenged and stuff.
Um,
and,
uh, just last year there's
something called the DMC I right.
The digital Millennium Copyright Act.
Um,
there's an exception for fair use
for educational purposes and for, um,
uh, for critical commentary, right. Uh,
and every year or every time it comes
up for review with the industry,
uh,
immediate district tries to get those
exemptions are projected and reduce or
reject fair use. Um, and they
come up with these ridiculous, uh,
schemes, you know, like you
will, you can use a DVD if you,
you know,
if you film it with a digital camera
off a screen in a dark room for 30 cm,
like all this stuff, right, which is not
what fair you says, but they're there.
They're trying to, to limited. Um,
and there've been some fantastic
organizations like organisation called the
Organization for transformative works
who has been trying to change that.
And last year they actually
want a great exception, um,
which is sort of already in fair
news, but it wasn't, it wasn't, uh,
it wasn't, uh, in the DMC A and it's,
it basically says that you're a Latin,
you are now allowed to rip
DVDs for fair use purposes.
Before you weren't allowed to do that,
which is a little ridiculous.
You would actually have to pirate to
the media to be legal. Right. Because,
because, you know, even though you could
use the media in a free and fair use,
the active decrypting,
the DVD was illegal.
And so he couldn't get the footage to use
in your classroom because you couldn't
do it through.
So what people would do is they would
download off the internet because someone
else had decrypted it. They had
done the illegal thing. Right.
That obviously ridiculous. And, and,
and, and, and the court found that,
that they made an exception to the DMC
I last year saying, well, you know,
if you're doing it for a fair use,
you've hit now decrypt the DVD.
And that's also fair.
Um,
so I feel like the fights that are
happening are happening on, on the, on,
on the advocacy. We that, but,
and I think that's where, yeah,
that's where I have faith
that things can change.
I hope that's helpful.
Oh, go for it. Do you see videos
and those educational media
interactive for, for what purpose?
Just educating the mass public.
It certainly is a very popular one.
I feel like I'm, you know, when I,
when I remixed things,
um,
I do it because I want people to see it
and I want a, I want a large audience.
I don't necessarily just want an audience
that agrees with me already or is in
my specific field. Right? Um, and
that's why he's popular culture,
because popular culture is this
sort of shared language, right? Um,
it sort of a common point that we
can come together and say, okay,
well we all understand this
reference point. Now we can
talk about what it means.
Um, uh, traditionally fine art video
for instance, hasn't done that.
Everybody who has been, um, created, uh,
for the most part for other artists and
for galleries and for academics. Right?
And so, um, what would I like about video,
especially pop culture video,
is that it creates this, this,
this space to have conversation
about some sort of very serious,
and I think deep issues.
Um, you know, uh, I, uh,
I also use video formats.
I think most people do video formats
that are also understandable, right?
So we all know what a trailer is,
right?
The trailer is actually a very
abstract thing, right? It's a,
in terms of filmmaking, it's not a
narrative really. It's sort of a, it's,
it's meant to give you the essence of
what something might be right in order to
see if you want to watch the entire thing.
Maybe that's an abstract concept.
There's, and you might get like hints
of narrative, but it's not a narrative.
It's a, it isn't, it's abstract. Um,
and the same way with tea, with TV ads,
TV ads are meant to give you an impression
of a feeling that associates with,
with a brand usually. Yeah. They're
usually not, this is cheap at this price.
Buy It. It's been, it, it's
cheaper than over here.
Like that's not actually what
most ads are. They're about there.
They're there about, uh, making
a brand emotional. And so, um,
a lot of remixers we'll then
use ads because ads are, again,
in abstract form that people
understand. Right? And music video,
we all understand what it means.
The video is right.
Even though it's actually a very
abstract thing. Um, uh, and so, uh,
if you're using those vehicles, you know,
like trailers and ads, right. That's,
that's, that's another way to,
to reach people that, that,
that maybe haven't been to,
um,
I mean he criticism class,
but do you know where trailers and
now they know where the trailer,
it looks like when it's,
you know,
when it's said Richard Dreyfus
falling in love with jaws. Right.
Which is a whole different
thing, but it's anyway, it's,
he gets inside of that those
Frank's right, that, that,
that vehicle frame and the
abstract frame. But it's, it,
it's a way to communicate
those ideas to people. Um, um,
I think in a much more
populist way. Right. Um,
so does that sort of answer that
question? I mean, I think that,
I think the educators are sort of lagging
behind in this field. I think that,
um, uh, certainly, you know,
half the students in this building or on
youtube right now and looking at video,
either learning or
laughing or both. And, uh,
and I feel like once you come into
this end, to the end of the classroom,
that should,
that should carry over video should become
an integral part because it's part of
the way people engage with the world.
Um,
and it's increasingly the way that
people engage with the Internet as well.
Videos,
Ada compliant.
That's a good question. Um,
well, so here's what I do. Um,
and it depends actually,
it actually,
that kind of means a lot of things. Um,
what I subtitle everything first of all.
So, um, and I use a universal sub
subtitles, which is a free sub title tool,
um, to give captions, um, as the,
those captions are in that program.
Um,
uh,
then I use translation tools
to let other people translate.
So it sort of broadens the reach,
um,
in as much as youtube is then yes. As
much as youtube isn't there. No. Right.
So,
um,
the infrastructure that people are using
for a lot of this video work right now
is, uh, is sort of based on what these
corporations have made available.
Right. Um, Youtube, uh, is working on it.
So they say we're going to a
lot of things. So they say,
and they're trying to make it better. Um,
they did that. They, you know, they have,
they have, um, they have, uh,
their voice to text tools.
I don't know if he's ever used them.
They're not very good yet. Um, I
find that, uh, that one of the,
one of the easiest things to
do is to read a transcript.
And this is something
that, that I, um, that I,
that I advocate for it with all my videos
and with other people who do videos,
you know, just making it make an English
transcript, uh, if, if it's an English,
upload it to Youtube,
uh,
upload it to wherever the video is so that
at least that option is available. Um,
and then, uh, with html
five or it's, I mean,
these are each trying to five
videos that are embedded, um, here.
Uh, and there's a whole bunch of, of, of,
of add ons that you can work with,
right.
And so those are sort of very slowly
being developed. I mean, for instance,
this presentation will only work in a, in
two browsers, right? Right. Now there's,
you know, it's not quite there yet,
but the possibility for, for, for,
for having video be integrated in I think
a much more accessible way does exist
with Asian or five where it
didn't exist. Right? You're,
you were stuck in youtube before.
Um, and like you saw with the,
with the dynamic and the
annotations happening, right?
[inaudible] you can imagine
that being done, um, uh,
with accessibility in mind. Right? And
building a whole app around that. Um,
and so because this is all
very experimental, you know,
people are sort of just beginning
to, uh, to, to, to play with that.
But I mean accessibility is,
I think for me crit critical and is
going to be critical for the web.
And I know that youtube,
at least Google is,
is it at least says it's
important to them. So
you said yesterday when we were
talking about loving the sores,
talk a little bit more about that. For
example, the dog gone thing versus, Hey,
I'm struck by is that music takes me
back to when I was like eight cause I
watched the same things
on the Disney channel.
There's somebody installed a trip there,
but you have to stare at these things
for days. How do you do months?
How do you do it? Well, so it's, it's um,
they're shipped to traditions, I
feel like, and this is a home top,
but there's two, two, two, two traditions
of sort of subversive remix video.
One of them and they both go
back to the mid seventies. Um,
one of them is called a
jammy or meaty, jammy. Uh,
and that is a pro practice of sort of
ridiculing media through remix video,
right? So we can go back to, uh, the
emergency broadcast network or Ebn, right?
Um,
uh,
we can go back to a whole bunch of
groups that were doing that kinda stuff.
The video scratchers in the
early eighties in, in the UK. Um,
often the relationship that those meaty
jammers have with media is entirely,
um, is entirely negative, right?
They are looking at media as a, as a, as a
brainwashing tool, Matt, mass mass media,
right? And that and that, therefore
they're going to ridicule it. Right?
And I'm not saying that that work.
Um,
there's a lot of fascinating
stuff that goes on with that work,
but that's one type of relationship
that is not necessarily the relationship
that I'd had with all media. There's
another tradition called the [inaudible],
which goes back to 1975, which
is fans per primarily, um,
doing what is essentially fan
fiction with video. Um, you know,
I'm using music and
using, um, and using, uh,
uh,
clips from mostly TV shows,
but increasingly some movies as well to
create using the lyrics to change the
meaning of the, of the
visuals. Visuals are changed,
the meaning of the lyrics and create a
new sort of fanfiction style story that
makes an argument or celebrates a
character or does a character study or
whatever. Um, and that, and
their relationship with their
source is very different.
Um,
they are also transforming and appropriate
in media and they have something to
say about that media,
but it's often a sort of very
sympathetic relationship with their,
with their, with their source. Um,
the way that I approach it as I take
a little bit from both. Right. So,
typically one of my sources will
be something I really enjoy. Um,
I feel like if you're gonna spend between
three and six months on a project at
watching this floor storage every day,
you probably don't want to
hate every minute of it,
right. Unless you're, you know,
you're enjoy pain, you
know. Um, and so, you know,
so I did a remix where I remixed the show.
So you think you can dance with the
presidential debates from 2008 and let me
tell you, I did not enjoy the time I
spent with the presidential debates. Uh,
it was excruciating and
painful and every minute of it,
I know I spent as much time with the
transcript as I could because I didn't
actually want to watch the video again.
Um, but, uh, but then I mixed it with,
so we think and dance, which I actually
is a show that I, that I enjoy. Um,
I feel there's a lot of constructive
criticism, sort of constructive criticism,
reality TV show model as opposed to
the ridiculous and making everyone cry
model, which is the more the x
factor kind of thing. So, um, uh,
so be at the auditions
are a little bit sketchy,
but after the auditions I feel like,
you know,
so I think in dance is actually
gets to a lot of sort of feels very,
it feels very different.
And so I liked that show.
I Oxford like the dances and so I could
like stop with Mccain and Obama and go
to, so wash them dances and
you know, really, um, and
enjoy my, my, my process with,
with, with that source. And I was kind of
a fan of that source. And so now for me,
I really love aspects of one thing and
I really dislike aspects of something
else. Um, but I think what
that gets back to is to,
is this idea that in the United States
especially, we have this idea that you're,
you, you either love something or hate
something, right? It's sort of like this,
this, this rigid, dogmatic binary. Um,
but I, I feel like when you're engaging
with media and when a lot of people are
engaging with media that isn't
made specifically for them. Like,
I'm very lucky because most media is
made specifically for me. Like literally,
they have a picture of me in mind,
right? A white, straight middleclass,
uh, English speaking
American, you know, um, uh,
and so they're making it for me. I,
Star Wars was made specifically for me,
mostly because most of the people
who were making these things are me.
Right? I mean, there, there
have been exactly my age and
exactly my, and everything.
So, um, uh, so I sort of expect
everything to be made for me.
And so when it's not made for
me, I get all annoyed. Right.
Um, uh, or I used to, uh,
and, but if it's not made
for you specifically, like
if, if I happen to be a,
if I happen to be queer, then I will
notice that this not made for me. Um,
I, I can still enjoy it. Right?
Probably we'll probably do, but, uh,
find something missing. Right.
Um, and so, you know, and if
you're coming from, um, uh,
from various other ethnic
communities in the United States,
you notice that media is not made
for you. Um, and so often people,
what we'll do when they watch media is,
is that that they'll have a
critical engagement, right?
Just in sort of a casual
curriculum and engagement,
which is that you can like some aspects
of it and be critical of other aspects
of it. Um, and what fans and fan fiction
often does. It says, well, you know what,
I really love the story.
I really love the concept.
I really love being on
the spaceship or whatever.
But it would be nice if there were
some people who kind of were like me,
I'm on a ship or, or people that I know.
Um, and so, uh, that's that relationship,
right?
It says loving something but being
critical at the same time and not having
those things contradict. And I
feel like, um, when I approach my,
my work,
I try to come from that perspective.
Yeah.
Well, software do you use, uh,
well that's a good question.
I have a small list here.
Assuming the Internet still works.
Um, it might be, yeah. Oh No,
it's fair. It's just, it's just slow. Uh,
so I have some of the tools up
here on platform makes video. Um,
so I use these,
these are mostly the free tools right
now in terms of like actual editing a,
I'm using a falcon pro.
Um,
but that is because there's no open
source alternative. Uh, there will be,
as of December 19th, December 19th,
I will no longer be using, uh,
I've, I'm gonna be using pocket probe
using light works and let works as an open
source professional video
editor. Um, uh, for instance,
detecting things that the king's speech
which won the academy award was edited.
Using light works.
Um,
the Beta is available for a
PC and on December 19th basis,
they promise it will be available
for Linux and Mac. Um, and so, uh,
I'll, I'll move to that.
Um, uh, I use these,
these various tools to
acquire media as well. Um,
I mean I get money from everywhere
and I get the, any from,
from youtube and I get media
from, uh, from bittorrent.
I get media from me. I mean,
depending on where I can get it. Uh,
I ripped DVDs, you know, all, all the,
all anywhere. You can kind of get it. Um,
uh, in some cases you have to, you know,
the crew though the Donald Duck one,
there was one clip,
there's a clip of the
Ajax employment agency.
And so if you don't know a lot about
Disney does Disney, and you're like acme,
the Acme company, the Acme
Corporation is this big looney tunes.
Like it literally is the only
company and all of Linton's. Well,
in Disney it's called Ajax. So it's the
same concept. There's one company. Um,
and so there's this, there's this
great scene where, you know, there's a,
the Ajax employment agency,
and that was a piece of footage that
I really wanted to use. However,
that piece of footage only exists as
filler footage between other cartoons,
uh, on the wonderful world of Disney
television show aired in the 1970s,
eighties. So if you don't have that and
no DVD, so if you don't have that, uh,
can I do it?
So I had to find someone who was a
collector and who was like a obsessive
compulsive collector of Disney material
who had a recording at when the show
aired in the mid eighties, I think on, um,
on the BBC in Manchester in the UK.
And he had a video tape of it and it was
able to trade with him via a very long
process. Something else that he didn't
have there was also very rare, uh,
so that he would then make a DVD rip
of that fee videotape. And then, right.
So there's a lot of software
involved in all that stuff. Um, uh,
but this is the main stuff that I use
and I'm going to, I'm out with my, on my,
on my workshop tomorrow. I'll
talk about it, we'll go over it
on your, on your list of topics. I
say you have a negative one in there.
And a negative, as I recall,
was about 10 years ago.
Got to a massive copy, right?
Metals, yes. A bad name to. Yes. And,
um,
my question is when you're talking
about about locking higher cars,
directors were risking that richer,
more powerful kind of shut
you down. Um, and why do you,
why? The question is how have you, I
mean obviously you're here at tech.
That's what'd,
which,
which is the corporation that is
basically written the cover. It was,
was it just the United
States right now? Um, so,
so when you're advocating the
use of this up was remission, um,
are you not also suggesting
that people are not
completely aware of all the power sectors?
Maybe asking for a lot of troubles?
I mean,
you could get into a lot of
trouble this. Yeah. I mean,
yes,
yes and no.
I feel like, um, some of the
reasons why I say yes and no,
it's because of the provisions in
the DMC. Yay. Um, so for instance,
I was to Remix Disney. First
of all, Disney's didn't care
so much about copyright,
how strangely, they care a lot
about trademark. Uh, and so,
uh,
what they care about is whether I sell
a tee shirt with Mickey mouse on it and
they don't get the profits.
That's what they care about.
Or that I put Disney on the side
of my daycare center or something.
That's what they care
about, what they, they,
but you can watch every single Disney
cartoon from the golden era on Youtube.
They have been uploaded by whoever for
free. And because I think that they're,
their reasoning in that is that this has
just sort of more brand recognition and
that's good. Um, so, uh,
I wasn't actually afraid of being
sued by them for that reason. Uh,
this is not commercial projects, so I
thought that was okay. I also have, um,
a lot of friends who are fair use
lawyers, so I have that in my corner. Um,
but even if I didn't,
uh,
what's the worst that could happen is
that I'm not hosting the video or most
people are not hosting the video. I
mean, I, I'm actually hosting the video,
but most people aren't. Most
people getting Google to
host the video. Right. Um,
and in the DMC Aa,
the way that it's that it's worded,
is it something called the
safe harbor provision, which,
uh, basically protects, um,
youtube or Vimeo or whatever the,
the middleman is right from lawsuits.
And so what will happen is
if they uploaded something
that Nike or Disney didn't
like or Mattel didn't like me to tell,
notorious actually, um, didn't like,
uh, they would send a new sort of
all happened inside of Youtube,
extra judicial process inside of the
DMC, a safe harbor, which is like,
which is that I would upload something,
uh,
Disney would send a takedown message,
not a notice because it's not legal,
it's extra legal to Google Youtube.
They would then remove it under the safe
harbor harbor version with no questions
asked.
If I wanted to get it back,
I would have to fill out
a form that said this. No,
I think this is a fair use in hand.
Here's why. And it might come back,
but I again, I'm not ever
being contacted, right.
Unless I actually file a counterclaim
with Disney. Right. Which is,
which is a whole different thing. It's
all youtube and youtube system. That's,
that's, that's working. So I'm not
actually going to be sued, right.
Unless I took it and put it the actual
video file on my thing on my site,
which people couldn't share you, you
know, it'd be be be, be a weird thing.
It has happened. I think
it's becoming, it's be,
it's pretty rare and often it blows up
in the face of the, of the media company.
Right. So it's, um, I feel like,
you know, in terms of this one, uh,
they just felt like, well,
if we say if we take it down,
that's just going to make it more
popular and you know, we won't do that.
So I feel like most media companies
are pretty smart about it. Um,
if it was a, a project, it would still
be fair use, but that, that, that,
that might earth than a little
bit. I, you know, um, but I'm,
I'm actually not concerned. I think
there's very, you know, people,
the worst that's going to happen to
most people is everybody is going to get
taken down by youtube and
with no legal action taken.
Oh,
you give an example of how you might
describe as a student assignment in a
course where you wanted to
introduce them to new media,
get them thinking about it
and actually doing some B,
what that assignment would look like.
Uh,
I can I,
can I come to tell you about assignments
that I've given and that could be
helpful? Maybe. Um, so one of
the things that I've found,
and this is this true for,
um,
for organizations that are trying to get
people to engage with social media as
well. I mean, if you're talking
about remix specifically,
which is mostly what I do,
um,
it's often really important to set
the parameters for what you expect,
right?
It's so sort of the last thing you,
the I think you want to do
is say go make a remix, uh,
anything using anything. Um, because often
that, that's just so overwhelming, right?
Um, I, what would I often
advocate for is to say, you know,
here's a piece of media or
here, two pieces of media,
or here's a series of ads,
Bucko Cola or whatever it is.
Um,
and I want you to use them in some way
to make a comment on them, but you,
you keep, you know, you, you,
you want to allow enough creativity
for there to be a lot of, um,
all of diversity in the response.
But you also don't want to sort of allow
for anything because that will be a
really overwhelming I think. Um, and
so often what I'll do like, you know,
in terms of the, of of the
re mixing tool, right? Um,
there's,
there's 800 possibilities and
they're all different possibilities,
but it's within a very
specific set of assignments.
So it's like saying, you know,
it's just saying swapped the audio and
the video from these two sets of sources
and see what you get. Um, um, and
so, you know, I, you can do this on,
you know, on the web or you could, you
could do a similar project you're using,
you know, ads for cleaning products and
tools and household, adult, you know,
gendered stuff. And you could say, swap
the audio in the video. Um, there are, uh,
image macros is another thing
that I then I often will use. Um,
so they're all these sites that will allow
you to top load a photograph and then
each person can type a different
sentence onto that, onto that. Right.
Um, and so it might be depending on what
your image is and what your, what your,
what your, what your topic is like the
privilege denying dude was about, um,
was what was sort of about
highlighting in a funny way,
a male privilege and the way that it
sort of manifests in the tech field
especially, but it sort of, you know,
went and talk kinds of directions. I mean,
there, there was a,
after, um, uh, after, uh,
the video monster came out, which is
a very sort of misogynist, um, uh,
video for, uh, Mr. West Song. Um, it,
it, someone made a privilege in nine dude
of him and do sort of like swapped out,
you know. All right, so you're, you're
then commenting on, you're using this,
this larger meme to comment on a
specific artist and a specific song. Um,
and so, um, often that kind of thing can
be, can be, can be cool. It can be like,
well, here's a, here's an
image macro where you can
type text on top of something.
It's about this sort of theme,
but then find other other characters
that might work. So whether it's Tucker,
Tucker, Tucker Carlson was one of them
that people used. Um, uh, there was,
there was a thing that happened with
the Keith Olbermann where he said some
pretty sexist stuff and then refuse to
apologize for it. People may want of him,
you know, for that, that was up for a
couple months. And so, you know, the,
the privilege of dude mean became more
than just, you know, it's, it's very,
it's very, very simple. It's, it's
one image and two sentences, right?
And in infinite combinations,
but that's it. And then you can,
you can swap out another image on the
same theme with two sentences, right?
So it's just sort of
constricting the possibilities,
but in that construction of possibilities
to creativity can become even more,
uh, even more exciting, I think.
So those are just some quick stuff.
You mean my life story?
You want to know how old
field or, um, so yeah. So, um,
so it's a, it's a long story.
Uh, I want to try to condense it.
I tend to go on and on. So, um, I, uh,
I was homeschooled. Um, and so, um,
for religious and military reasons,
um, my family's very
conservative and, and uh,
which I'm not, but uh, they are. And, um,
until I spent a lot of time
playing has education. So my,
in a very odd way,
the reason I was being kept
home was because of very,
very fundamentalist religious beliefs.
But the educational philosophy
is that my parents had,
was actually very progressive. Um,
so it sort of an unschooling process.
And so,
um,
a lot of that was sort of a
facilitated or directed play,
right? So a lot of Legos and a lot of
audio books and a lot of, you know,
a lot of projects that I could,
that I could sort of follow me out of
my interests. Um, and so, uh, you know,
in that process of, of, um, of learning,
learning was always fun for me.
It always about finding things out and
figuring things out. And, you know, like,
I mean for me, researching
the history of, of, of,
of the Disney animators at the studio
was really kind of fun because, you know,
I wanna know what's happening. Each thing
I learned, I feel like it's, it's, it's,
it's a fun game,
right?
But I feel like that a little bit
unique to a very specific kind of
homeschooling. Oh, philosophy.
And, um, and so when I went,
when I did go to high school, I went to
a magnet art school in Baltimore City.
And, um, and it was, it was sort of a, it
was a very, uh, it was very structured,
but it was also a, you know,
it was it an art school.
So I was doing picker painting
and drawing, and I was doing,
I was really interested in, in, in, in,
in artistic creation. Um, I went to,
I went to college, I went to school. I
had no grades, no attendance records,
you know, um, uh, there
was no required courses.
I mean, you could literally
not go the entire semester,
but then you wouldn't get any credits.
I mean,
the way that you got credits was
that you presented your work,
everything you'd done in every field that
you were interested in for that entire
year, and they gave you
credit space on that or not.
So 15 credits or zero credits,
you still have to pay for it either way.
Um, but you, um, that was, that
was sort of very hovers it,
it's very high pressure and a lot of ways,
but it sort of let you self direct.
And so that was what I was interested in,
in, in, in doing and figuring out. Um,
there's also no majors at that school,
the museum school in Boston
Museum School in Boston, um,
no major. So you could bounce between
disciplines. I mean, and the, I,
the idea being that if you're being, if
you're a creative or sort of artistic, uh,
in, in, in, in your work,
then you will just find whatever medium
it is that best represents the idea that
you're trying to get across. And so that's
what we do. I'd be like, Oh, you know,
this,
this idea would best work in animation,
so I'll go and learn that next
semester, you know, or whatever. Um, um,
but he allowed me to learn technology
in a way that I wouldn't have otherwise,
which is that,
you know,
most of the time I just camped out in
the Mac lab and eventually they gave me a
job there. And then, uh, cause I was just
there all the time and then, uh, and,
and learned and taught applications
that way, um, including video editing.
Um, and then when the, when the war in
Iraq started, I was very upset and, uh,
I took the, just recorded the TV ads
and all and put them together into,
into remixes and that sort of how
that process happened. And, and,
and in that process of, of, of,
of doing and learning, you know,
I mean certainly there was no class on
remix. Um, but doing and learning, um,
and figuring out, well, I want to put this
on the Internet, but there's no youtube,
no, 2003. What do you do? A,
I guess you have to find the Kodak and
then you'd have to find some software
somewhere that we'll put it up.
And then you have to, you know,
like get a server and like all that stuff.
And so I did all that stuff. And, um,
and that's sort of how I've learned over
time is by doing that, is that helpful?
Is that kind of what you meant? And
then, then he invited me to come here. So
that's the short version
five.
Yeah. I mean, all of them
to leave by the way I look
or talk or ask questions.
I mean,
sure.